FINISHED DOWN 61.
♪ ♪
TONIGHT'S DEMOCRACY 2020 REPORT,
JOE BIDEN IS UP AND MOST
NATIONAL POLLS BUT SOME OF THE
CROWDS IN THE FIRST PRIMARY
STATE DO NOT SEEM TO BE HAPPY
WITH ALL HIS ANSWERS.
CORRESPONDED ELLISON BARBER
REPORTS TONIGHT FROM
NEW HAMPSHIRE WHERE BIDEN IS
ONCE A AGAIN WHERE HE WOULD
REDACT TO A CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENA.
>> WOULD BE FINE.
>> TODAY, FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN INC. GOT WITH THE
EDITORIAL THE REPORT AND FOR THE
FOURTH TIME IN AS MANY DAYS HE
TRIED TO CLARIFY WHAT HE MEANT W
TRIED TO CLARIFY WHAT HE MEANT E
TRIED TO CLARIFY WHAT HE MEANT N
HE TOYED
"THE DES MOINES REGISTER" HE
WOULD NOT COMPLY WITH A
SUBPOENA TO TESTIFY THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
>> WE WOULD DO IT AGAIN.
THERE IS NO RATIONAL BASIS.
FOR ME BEING CALLED INTO THE
IMPEACHMENT.
>> WITH THE SEVEN WEEKS TO GO,
RECENT POLLS SHOWING THAT
HAMPSHIRE IS STILL UP FOR GRABS.
OF MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG, BIDEN,
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS ARE ALL
WITHIN THREE POINTS OF EACH
OTHER.
SANDERS WHO SUFFERED A HEART
ATTACK EARLIER THIS YEAR GOT A
BILL OF GOOD HEALTH.
ACCORDING TO THE SANDERS
CAMPAIGN, THE SENATOR'S
CARDIOLOGIST AT THIS POINT HE'S
CONFIDENT THAT SANDERS HAS THE
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL STAMINA TO
FULLY UNDERTAKE THE RIGORS OF
THE PRESIDENCY.
PETE BUTTIGIEG IS ONE OF THE TWO
REMAINING 2020 CANDIDATES WHO
SERVED IN THE MILITARY.
RIGHT NOW, THE MAYOR WHO IS
DEPLOYED TO AFGHANISTAN IS GOING
AFTER THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
FOR HIS VOTE ON THE WAR IN IRAQ
WHILE HE WOULD STILL IN THE
SENATE.
>> THIS IS AN EXAMPLE WHY YEARS
IN WASHINGTON IS NOT ALWAYS THE
SAME THING AS JUDGMENT.
HE SUPPORTED THE WORST FOREIGN
POLICY DECISION MADE BY THE
UNITED STATES IN MY LIFETIME.
>> BIDEN IS SWINGING BACK.
>> I RESPECT HIS SERVICE.
I AM THE GUY, AND POINTED OUT
REPEATEDLY, THAT I THOUGHT WE
SHOULD NOT BE GOING INTO
AFGHANISTAN.
>> PETE BUTTIGIEG ATTACKED UP
BIDEN'S RECORD IN THE SENATE AND
PROTESTERS AND TOWN HALL WHERE A
LITTLE BIT MORE PERSONAL.
SPEAK OUT LET GO, LET HER GO.
>> HOW MUCH MONEY CAN YOU MAKE
AN UKRAINE?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP REFUSES TO DO
RELEASE TO OVER 20 YEARS OF HIS
TAX RETURNS AND THE NEXT
FUND-RAISING DEADLINE IS
TOMORROW.
OF THE MIKE SENATOR WARREN SENT
A LETTER SAYING THAT THEY'RE
AIMING FOR A $20 MILLION THIS
QUARTER AND THEY ARE NOT THERE